[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in this brief video i wanted to address
the rumors surrounding a likely
candidate for the potential recasting
of the role of gelat grindelwald in the
fantastic beasts film franchise
as johnny depp was asked to resign by
warner brothers just a few days ago
amidst a domestic abuse scandal there
has been a lot of speculation
as to what will happen to the film
franchise moving forward despite
depth leaving the film franchise they
will continue as planned
and the company is actually filming the
third installment as we speak
when it comes to the recasting of the
role that he plays there have been a lot
of names tossed up into the air
but one name appears to be appearing
more and more often
overshadowing the rest mass mikkelson
it's now looking as though maz
is first in line to take over the role
as the dark wizard
and given that depp had only finished
filming one scene before being asked to
resign
it should be a fairly seamless
transition though not entirely confirmed
the main rationale behind the countless
reports of mass being chosen for the
role
stems from david yates the director of
the film franchise
yates of course famously brought the
magical world to life in the order of
the phoenix
the half-blood prince and the deathly
hallows part one and two
and now his goal is to bring that same
magic to the fantastic beasts franchise
it has been reported that maz is david's
first choice for the dark wizard
and given that he's directing the film
and that so many fans independently came
to the decision that maz was a good
choice
he's almost a shoe-in for the role maz
mickelson is a danish actor that first
came to prominence in the year 1996
for his role as tony in the pusher film
trilogy the actor
born in 1965 is actually closer in age
to jude law who was born in 1972
than depp which is more canonically
consistent given that grindelwald's
character is actually two years younger
than dumbledore
the dane also hails from denmark in
northern europe which is much closer to
the birthplace of grindelwald which is
thought to be somewhere in central
europe
like leap hungary maz fits the
description for grindelwald's character
on so many levels
and he's certainly not shy to playing
the bad guy nicholson's breakout
performance
the role for which he received worldwide
recognition was his role as le chief
in the 21st james bond film casino
royale which premiered in 2006.
since then maz has taken on numerous
other villainous roles
such as cassilius and doctor strange and
hannibal lecter himself
in nbc's tv series hannibal i think
mikkelsen has the background
the look and the demeanor to play
grindelwald and i'm anxiously awaiting
confirmation
that he will be taking on the role what
do you guys think will you embrace
mikkelsen in the role
do you think he's a good fit let me know
in the comment section below
until next time it does not do too well
on dreams and forget
to live
[Music]
you